Hi everyone we open up this chapter by taking a look at the strategic view of bargaining this is going to carry over with the game theory that we studied in the previous chapter so let's go ahead and jump into it.
We're going to start with a simple game here in which you and your employer are bargaining over position. Now you are a newly minted MBA so you have learned a thing or two.  What we're going to do first is look at the strategies that you have in the playoffs available to you you can bargain hard or you can accept now if you bargain hard you have payoffs of $0 and eighty thousand dollars.
If you accept you have payoffs of $40,000 and fifty thousand dollars we can see that there is no dominant strategy for you because 0 is less than 40 but 80 is greater than 50. Now your employer also has the same strategies they can bargain hard and get 0 or 60,000 or they can accept and get 20,000 or 50,000 what we can see again is that we have no dominant strategy for being so this leaves us with the situation in which how do we solve this game? Well let's put this into the game tree form so we can see if you have a first-mover advantage. What might you do and what might your employer do based off of what they think you are going to do so if we look at this game.
We still have bargain hard and accept as our strategies and we moved down to the second node which is where the employer is now from here we're going to start looking at the payoffs that are available to us with the employer we noticed that if you bargain hard and they bargain hard we still get the same payoffs of $0 for each of them.
If we look at the bargain hard and accept you get the 80,000 and the employer gets the 20,000.
If we go to the other side and we do accept and bargain hard we see that you get forty thousand in the employer gets 60,000. If we both accept then we both come out with $50,000. Now what  do we do? Let's compare your payoff first we have zero and 80 and we see that 80 is better, so if the employer sees that you are willing to bargain hard then they're going to accept.
Now if we look at the other side we see that that you get 40000 vs 50,000, so if you accept it's in your best interest to have the employer also accept but let's look at what the employer does the employer can get 60,000 versus 50,000 so in this case the employer is going to bargain hard if you accept.
What does that mean? That means that you should go in and you should bargain hard and the employer should accept because you would much prefer to have $80,000 compared to the other payoffs that are available and the employer would prefer to have a 20,000 versus the $0 that they would get if they chose to bargain hard.
So in this case having the first mover advantage is going to be advantageous.
for you. Now that's going to be advantageous for anybody.
Let's take a look at this example. Now this one's pretty easy because we see firm one chooses between payoffs of 4 and 6 vs 7 and ten. So we know that firm one is always going to choose high price which means firm two has to choose between 0 and -2 or excuse me, 0 and positive 2, and we know that firm two is going to take a positive two. So this is our Nash equilibrium.But now let's look at what happens if we were to change the payoff structure such that we have firm one not having a dominant strategy between low price and high price. Now we can say neither the same thing for firm two because they'd rather have zero than -2 but they'd rather have 2 than 0. So what firm one might do is have a credible threat by going ahead and building excess capacity and go ahead and price low for the short run. So here you price low in the short run as firm one you earn a either a 4 or a 6 and it's likely that firm two was going to choose high price which means they're not going to get any sales so what's taking place is with firm one
they are making a short-term decision in order to have a long-term gain because they have the ability to have that excess capacity which means they can expand to that. Now that whole scenario revolves around the principle that they needed a credible commitment they needed a credible threat. That is not going to be...that always won't be the case that you won't actually have that happen for you. You really don't want to have to use that credible threat because you noticed that in the top game what we see is that the high price they had seven but in the bottom game they had a 3 so they had to to use that credible threat in order
to, uhh, inorder to induce firm 2 to not enter into that market, but if they did what they can do is go ahead and lower that price in the short run and in anticipation of firm two exiting the market in the long run so then they could go back and make more money make more profit. Right let's conclude last game here we have a firming have a resource supplier we have strategies of low ball and accept the firm is in re negotiations with their resources flyer and we can see the payoff there that we have if we have firm low-balling and the supplier.
Then we get pay off three and four if the firm low balls and the supplier except we get paid off of 5 and 2 so if we just look at this game tree that single note we see that the firm would prefer to lowball in have the supplier except.
But we also see that the supplier if the firm low balls is going to also low-ball because the four is greater than the two so it's very difficult to decide what's going to take place now if we look at the other side of the game tree have accept and then we have the supplier either low-balling or accepting as well.
If the firm accepts and the supplier lowballs we see the payoff of 2 and 5.
And if the firm and the supplier both accept the contract then what see are payoffs of three and three. Now the firm will choose accept because we see the three is better than the two but again the resource supplier is not going to do what the firm wants because the 5 is greater than what we have to do is get down to a situation in which the firm can do some backwards induction and get to the arena with lots of another firm is going to either get three.
If the supplier takes lowball because that's what the supplier will do to firm chooses lowball, or the firm will get two if the firm does accept because the supplier will choose lowball on top of that so the three is greater than the two and so what we might see is that the supplier and former both want to choose lowball.
But what if there was a situation in which we had
this? What if there was a credible commitment that came out
and we see that the supplier just go ahead and says look, this is not going to happen. We are going to walk if you do not come to terms with our agreement. So the firm here chooses to accept and then we will see the supplier choose to lowball. So again another credible committment, credible threat scenario in which the one party or one player of this game was able to make a line in the sand and the other party did not cross that line and what we would end up seeing is the firm choosing to accept and the supplier lowballing the offer so that the firm gets a payoff of two and the supplier gets a payoff of 5. Alright, that is it for strategic bargaining we will catch you in nonstrategic bargaining.